models of huge objects in both I cannot
wait to not be the chair anymore
I have a little chart here
I'm enjoying every talk
so hello everyone
um so I'm going to talk about the
initial code generative models of huge
objects and this is a joint work with
Omar rheingold and learn Yahoo which are
both here
um so I'm going to start by this giving
some background and motivation then I'm
going to to say what we mean by having a
generative model from a single huge
object
um I'm going to show how like existing
techniques learning techniques also work
in this like huge object setting
um then I'm going to talk about one
example where existing techniques not
really work and we need to do
um more things and I'm going to finish
by
presenting some open directions
so
um for a really start I'm going to start
by like a motivating example
suppose I want to analyze the graph
representing the internet but I have a
really simple analysis I want to do I
don't actually need all of its
complexity I don't actually need
uh everything I just maybe want to know
how much we have connection between two
large uh domain I don't know West Coast
and Ascot so I don't really want the
graph representing the internet what I
really want is some something which
looks like the graph representing the
internet to my purpose
and I would hope that this thing would
be small
so that I would not have to store this
huge graph
so sort of what I want is a small
implementation
that for the purpose of my analysis
looks like the graph representing the
internet
so this is like a high level motivation
to keep in mind and sort of what's the
difference
so the model is so the implementation is
like a random sample out of this model
because we want to sort of use the
randomness
so the idea is that on average a random
implementation would look like a graph
representing the internet
um thank you so this is like a
motivation and
um to formalize it we're going to use
the setting by goldbuster
that they talked about huge random
objects but before I'm going to talk
about
um huge random objects I'm going to talk
about the standard pseudorandom setting
um in which we're trying to create an
object that appears to be random
so for example we have all Android text
graph
and we want an algorithm that uses less
than N squared bit of Randomness but
outputs a graph which seems to be random
and um and what we mean by seem to be
random so like in many previous stuff we
have some class of distinguishers that
get either G prime or G not both of them
together and sort of what we want
is that this this all distinguishers in
the class are going to act more or less
the same whether they get a real
random graph or they get something
generated by our algorithm
so this might be polynomial algorithm
might be less complex
so in the setting of DDM they introduce
the idea of having a random object which
is huge
so in this case instead of M being like
poly n where n is the rhyme time of this
algorithm here we can think about the
number of vertices as being exponential
and then um clearly the distinguisher
cannot even read paragraph
so in their setting
the distinguisher has query access to
either a completely random graph or to a
graph which is an implementation
um and then but the requirement the
indisting requirements is still the same
but now instead of having reading this
entire object we only have gray axis
so
um another thing you can see is it's not
only that the distinguisher cannot read
this in paragraph
but also this algorithm cannot write
this entire graph because the graph is
exponential
so this is why this work is about also
implementation of huge right now because
now
unlike in the normal so the random
setting the algorithm does not actually
outputs the random object it outputs on
small implementation that can answer
queries if this is a graph is there an
edge between new and V
um yes
do you assume that do you allow the
implementation to have stay and be
probabilistic
good once you once you output
the key the graph there'd be a actual
single graph that's determine so like
the implementation
um
can be pluralistic but once you have
like for for every random string there
should be a graph underlying like you
cannot answer inconsistent results about
like an edge or something
you both don't have access to the edges
like so there is some some like graph
but it's not explicitly represented so
it's like represented by this
small implementation
so
um the distinguisher can so so the
vertex set is just one to end so but so
the question with our interests us is
like
if there exists an edge between certain
vertices
um and then this works they also
introduce the idea of having
truthfulness conditions in which sort of
if we assume our graphs have some
additional Global property for example
suppose we listen all and it's graph
that have exactly K edges this is a
global property so it cannot be verified
by the distinguishers which only can
query edit but if all the graphs were
trying to imitate have it we also want
that all the implementation we have
should also satisfy it and regardless of
this property not being able to be
distinguished by our distinguishers
um so what we're doing in in our work
was to take this setting that ggm
introduced and to treat this setting in
the idea of a generative models so
sort of the high level ideas
so maybe you know I have only simple
analysis but over time
I still want to be consistent with the
global property I know the graphical
internet has so regardless of one
um it's not a real necessary to achieve
but it's a good question I remember you
were offering it to your thoughts
you know this joke but uh
so let's go this way there is a reason
one can give but regardless it's
mathematically it's a different object
object or anything you can support some
operations and maybe you couldn't
support
because you could think about a case
where you have a track
suppose you're looking so the outside
world it looks the same but you because
you have something
that enables you because it satisfies
some true property to give answers to
some questions because
I think the question was some
things
also the random fermentation
no but he can ask why do you care if you
can't tell them
so again I think it's when you can do
some operations
what kind of access you allowed
allow that you have so I'm going to talk
about it
um
not right now
so like in a very high level if we want
to create a model which sort of look
like a specific
graph so we assume we have a single huge
object and a distinguisher like before
um
and sort of we want to replace it so in
our case the distinguishers only
receives samples from either the huge
object or our implementations like
random edges from the graph we do not
know how to handle Aquarius and like we
have we have a result saying you cannot
handle queries in this setting
the graph regular intercase
but not like is there an act between you
and me this kind of words we don't know
um yeah so now in a more formal way
we have a single huge object
and we wanted to have indistable models
so we have a collection of
distinguishers and we want to Output a
model that outputs now randomly and
implementation and we want this to be
the same with respect to our set of
distinguishers so we're actually missing
something here which is that we need to
learn this huge object because this is
now a specific huge object we're not
trying to generate a random object
um so we have to have an additional set
that has a learning algorithm that has
um some samples also from our huge
object and then this learning algorithm
should generate our model
um so this is like in in a very high
level and in a more specific setting
okay sorry this I forgot to say so if
the huge object is very complex then
clearly we cannot learn something which
is actually close to it
so sort of um like in many previous
talks here we're learning it with
respect to our set of distinguishers so
we're only learning the properties of
this B star with that the distinguishers
actually check
um and in a more
so we have a set of distinguishers they
have in this case this is only sample
access and not actually query access but
we still want this to be the same
and in
um every specific instance what do we
mean we have a huge object now it can be
a specific graph or a specific function
or other object but we only handle
graphs and functions
and then it is also defined by a set of
distinguishers because the learning
algorithm now has to know ahead the set
of distinguishers you need to be
indistinguishable with respect to
because else it would not know which
properties of this B Star it needs to
learn
and and if we have truthfulness
conditions then we also need to know
them ahead of time
so all these like the final instance and
this is the setting we
um
we learn
um and our result so what we're going so
we introduced this idea of having uh
indistinguishable generative models for
huge objects and in some cases existing
results like I'm going to talk in a
month about the weak regular art dilemma
just works directly also in this setting
um in some specific cases standard
results do not directly work for example
if we want a truthfulness condition and
so in the work of DDM they had a
random function with a fixed support of
size okay
um and we can also do it in the case
that we're trying to learn a specific
function with respect to some set of
distinguishers
um it is more complex complex because
sort of you need to trace exactly how
many ones you gave to any kind of
subset of your set but at the same time
to be similar to your input function
um and also we show a result about
sparse graph that I'm going to talk
about
um later on so
here it is
so you're saying uh today and learning
they come up with generated models and
the definition of what Success is Not
distinguished outcomes you're saying in
addition to that you want to impose on
these things that you cannot distinguish
something that's true yeah
experience no in the same way that uh
somebody who asked why I asked you why
in your context yeah so in our context
and what I can think of is that
sometimes maybe you know I only want to
run a very simple analysis on my
internet
yeah but like over time if I know the
breakfast some some large property like
I would like to keep it because it might
affect me
but I don't have like a very specific
use case so why wouldn't
for that first in a specific content
where the truthfulness requirement is
that basically a special case or
visibility and function
because you can just build the domain as
many times V and then the function is
the true Edge function and I'm just
trying to
simulate it
in a way that you cannot distinguish a
random sample from the true function and
the random sample from the simulated
function
I'm not sure okay
the distance we should only have sample
excess
means
from the possible yeah and tell me
whether there is an edge or not and then
um is from some distribution
isn't it just the same as
learning a function where my domain is
basically now switch to V times B my
function is basically the edge function
and I want to find so for for just for a
graph you can treat it as like you can
reduce from learning a function to
running around change
I think that was your question yeah yeah
you can also reduce learning the graph
which you are learning a function
basically the functions yeah so the
specific yeah yeah
so without the truthfulness it's not so
in a specific case of spark so that I'm
going to talk about there is also
something that
um at least we don't have a function
analog for what we can do first pass
graph
um so I would uh I think I would just
get that later on and but the the
standard result about just learning a
function with no restriction and
learning a draft with no restriction or
practical adjustment yes
okay so I'm going to start by like a
existing results how they just work
which is I think
we talk a lot but I'm going to Define so
we have an object it's a specific dense
graph it has
um oven Square edges
we have distinguishers that only receive
a single edge so this would be a single
random Edge each one has two sets of
vertices and it accepts If U is in V1
and V is in V2
so this is the standard setting of the
weak regularity Lemma that was actually
mentioned here quite a lot before
and in the simplest case where we have
disjoint V's you can even think about
just having four sets of vertices and
distinguisher just check how many edges
are between these four sets
then
our learning algorithm just needs to
know
in this graph G Prime what is the
approximate what is the edge probability
with respect between each of these sets
and then the model could just be these
four sets and the probabilities between
them now because we're in this huge
object case we also need to have an
implementation
so in this case we can easily do it by
rejection sampling we sample to because
we need to generate samples from our
implementation
so we sample two vertices and we just
output UV with probability POV and with
probability one minus P will be where
Pub is just the P of their groups we
repeat this
and this would work as long as this p is
constant so that would stop it's not
going to work for a sparse graph
[Music]
um
so are you trying to answer queries
you're trying to generate generate
samples from from a graph that looks
like this distance the fraction of edges
in the graphs that are between you and
me so so sorry POV is just the
probability which is like let's say p12
If U is in V1 and V is
so this is just the so my model just
remembers like the the fraction of edges
between the two the four vertical sense
the fraction of edges and the gram for
the fraction of edges out of all the
possible edges between V1 and V2 how
many edges actually exist yeah like it
it approximately probability of a random
Edge between V1 and V2 in in g-star
when you say sample during the figure
no these are completely two random two
random practices and TUV is like a few
view of the cluster yeah
but if we have a slightly more complex
set of distinguishers which are
learnable so what I mean by this is the
same as I think was in before here that
if we have Sandeep distinguisher that
says there are more orthodoxone then we
we can approximate these sets u and v
that are the set of this percentage
and then by boosting algorithm which is
actually the same Niche membership model
as ddv
we get a mixed membership model
like the same result exactly the
boosting algorithm gives us
um a mixed membership model and now Pub
is not just P of of the part that
belongs to you and Vivid like a sum
overall
partition of the wolves in algorithm so
this is
like the existing work just we have this
extra implementation but this would not
work for a Sparks graph
sorry I think I missed the setup can you
go to the right side that one before the
one before yeah you have to Output an
edge no type of vertices and safe love
connected yeah you have to Output like a
random ad from your graph so so the
object is just an arbitrary graph that
yeah it's like it fixed every very rough
that you're trying to interface and then
how you are learning is by learning a
partition right so the partition here is
is given by the distinguishers so I
assume the distinguishers have rotation
that we can that we can we know about it
oh I see that I see and then the
distinguisher is just checking whether
the density yeah we're just checking out
so this is exactly the setting of the
week regularity llama
um if if we generalize this set of
distinguishers to be
if this is just a set of this
interesting and they're learnable side
of the same shows then the boosting
algorithm of TTV for
when viewed in a week regular dilemma
is is going to give this model
so um
slightly different from what I remember
isn't that easy
that the distinguishers are cuts and
then the what you want to learn
English is a partition and then
so
this I mean the signature checking
whether there exists an edge between two
sets of vertices is actually
yeah
this is why it sort of the same
so
um
in this case would it work for a sparse
crop
so um in a spacecraft the number total
number of edges is both and square it's
n
so
first of all the the error in the case
of a spouse graph if my distinguisher
receives a random Edge the error scales
at the number of edges in the graph
so
um this means our error is is something
like not Epsilon N squared but Epsilon n
so this is this can be a problem because
the the normal boosting algorithm would
just give us an N squared error
but also we cannot do rejection sampling
because we are in this setting where we
have huge object and we want to generate
edges from it
sort of we don't know how to generate
random edges from a sparse graph based
on these models
so what we do is is sort of object
because we create a dense model
for the sparse graph that we get
um
so the idea is that we have
even if we know the graph is sparse we
still create a dance model we know it's
not going to be close to our graph but
sort of with respect to the probability
of a random Edge to cut to to go through
all the cuts the fine brow set of
distinguishers we're going to be
indistinguishable
um so this is our ethereum if we have a
sparse graph but we can only do it for
sparse graph that have no non-stop
graphs and
um we have a learnable set of
distinguishers then we can output a
model that is indistinguishable
um with respect to our set of
distinguishers
um and what we the way we're doing it in
a very high level
is by using
um
the strong regularity level yes
can we go back
the same the same set of distinctures I
had before but HD each distinguisher
receives
I can add and accept cpusion V and if
there is a distinguisher that is not
um
so there's like an information theoretic
result here but also computational
result we're saying first
whether they're learnable or not you can
build an object yeah they are learnable
in polynomial time then maybe you can
even learn it
so
if we do not have any kind of learnable
restrictions this is in some case in
some sense
that like just derived from the the
record now the stronger now
so like the the interesting case that
what we have is that we still need to
learn
okay so in in a very high level
what we're doing is we receive our
learning algorithm receive samples from
from our sparse graph G Star
but from the stronger variety Lemma for
sparse graphs with that have node and
subgraph we know that there exists a
dense graph G Prime
that is indistinguishable from our input
and this is a distinguishable in not
with respect to a set of distinguishers
but actually in this like for any any
cut like in a strong regular dilemma
um so this is for the stronger artillery
for sparse props and
we sort of pretend that our algorithm
have sample access to D Prime and not to
J
and we're learning this Jeep we're
learning this model for G Prime and
um
and then we show that this model is also
indistinguishable for our original
um graffiti
um and at the previous we don't have an
analog of anything we're doing here in
the case of a function
because sort of the idea of a dense
craft with out sorry a sparse graph
without dense subgraphs this entire
object does not really have
um or at least we don't have an analog
for that in in the setting of a function
well there are
[Music]
generalizations I mean this is
essentially the special the graph
version is a special case of the dense
model third
so you're saying you're saying should be
using the dance model
s
a function analog for this yes so that's
interesting I would look into it
and so
so in a high level this is what we're
doing in the first trap and I'm going to
finish by by talking about oven question
because we sort of view this work as
like
um
introducing this model and there are a
lot of things that we don't know how to
do
um and and I'm going to talk about some
of them so the first thing is we only
handle functions and like binary
functions actually and simple graphs we
have some results about non-binary
functions but they're not very
interesting because we don't know how to
do an interesting set of distinguishers
um so I think this is very interesting
to try and figure out if we can do
something there and and for this that's
actually about your comment currently
the only result we have for a sparse
object is the sparse graph and that
would be very interesting to see if we
can extend it to some sort of
cross-functions or find other sparse
objects because it seems to be
inherently more difficult to handle
sparse objects than dance ones
um
also currently the distinguishers we
know how to handle are um sort of
independent like a single edge or a
single entry but we don't know how to
handle distinguishers that like take
multiple edges and try to check if there
exists some subgraph or some sort
um and with like that would be very
interesting to handle
and also if we can do truthfulness with
respect to more properties than like the
number of edges total number of edges or
the total number of ones in a functions
so and this is it thank you
[Applause]
my first question
um
okay so when you so in your notion of
implementation for this kind of uh
generation
like a sampling procedure that gives you
random images
um but as far as I can tell
directly you don't necessarily get a a
particular graph that you're sampling
from
that you know you could in principle
um be sample from any particular Edge if
you like sample enough yes so but you
could like do something I think you
could do something a little bit
different and have a particular graph in
mind like take a pseudorandom function
and use that to define whether you're
doing the regression example yes that's
actually I was sort of ignoring it in
the talk but actually in the work of PDM
they showed how you can do it with the
sudanum function and we're building upon
the result but yeah for Simplicity I I
didn't um
yeah I want to just like I remember uh
there are algorithms that uses this sort
of problems
to show them for dance crafts
and the reason that the only stop is
because the only customer like that's
graph otherwise the error which is
absolute with a fraction of b square it
will be too large
but now that you have something that
simulates a sparse object I just wonder
if there's any
Mine
The Learning problem might be hard
so I mean it might be first that's far
scrap with no dense solid rocks are
still easy with perspective because this
is not on any Express Scrap we sort of
need and and we also know that if we
have a sparse graph that have a dance
subgraph at least our method doesn't
generalize okay so it might be the smart
scrap because this sparse graph are sort
of random like
um there are sort of uniforms so it
might be easier on them as well I see
thank you
sorry uh so since you've transported
this idea of usefulness
to a generator settings I was wondering
whether some kind of environmental
definition so if their thing exists now
you
um right you have to say properties on
it there's no notion of building it up
so the reason I've been picking it is
because somebody asked to like why we
wanted we're saying about to live in the
future
um
speaking about the idea you have an
object I know you want to extend it in
the future
I'd like to to refine with the largest
set of distinguishers
the internet is going to grow even it's
going to grow but you want to make sure
it doesn't grow something is true about
this
um
[Applause]
you have an object Ive
but over time over time and how much it
would cost you to make it bigger in
filmmaking
which is something will not come up yeah
so does you have an object and now uh
yeah
so we have a lunch break and uh we
should all be back here promptly
foreign